اذا بالفعل كيف تعرف ان طفلك موهوب يبدا
ذلك بملاحظه بعض المفارقات التي تظهر
عليهم منذ سنوات الاولى ومن اهم السمات
السلوكيه التي رصدتها مؤسسه موهبه ملاحظه
ان الطفل يعقد مقارنه لاكتشاف العلاقات
بين الاشجار ويطرح الكثير من الاسئله
الجديره بالاهتمام
وعرض مشكلات حسب ما يتاح لها واعطاء بدائل
متعدده لمشكله واحده
وقد يقدم اجابات الاسئله بشكل اكبر من عمر
الزمني ويربط النتائج بالاسباب الطفل
الموهوب ايضا يجرب الاشياء الجديده ولديه
قدره على ادراك المساحات والاحجام
والمسافات ويستطيع ايضا ان يتعامل مع
الارقام والرموز الرياضيه بسهوله ويستوعب
المبادئ والقواعد الرياضيه ليوسف كما انه
يتمتع بخيال واسع ولديه ثقه بنفسه وبارائه